honor code take one can you recite the
honor code
no a hill Silla college student is
honorable indeed okay is honorable and
word indeed though still a college
student is honorable in word and deed my
Michelle will probably know it my house
a college student is honorable and
conduct honest and word indeed beautiful
and study and service and he attends
classes freedom because the liberal arts
respectful of the rights of others
brushing your teeth it's good to brush
your teeth people it's not late to
meetings okay I need my next line please
rising to education No can you recite me
Annika yes I can
I host a college student is honorable
and conduct honest and worden being
dutiful and study in service and
respectful of the rights of others
through education a student rises to
self-government thanks I I have to be
able to do for my job let me start all
of our meetings we were set the honor
code you know senior class secretary I
need to have these things memorized it's
incredible how these things like how the
words of the honor code how I don't
remember the specific phrasing but like
it's integrated into my life when I
first heard that does that I'm not a
coach it was that dr. Arnn speech that
he gave at the beginning here and it was
a pretty like strange sort of
interesting thing that I'm not really
used to having like codes you know given
to me I went to a public high school so
we never had anything like that I think
I was on like a little tour around
campus and we were down by the cavity
and they said something about oh yeah
people just leave their backpacks in
their MacBooks and their wallets and
their phones everywhere because we have
an honor code so no one touches anything
I had never heard anything like an honor
code ever especially around a college
campus the first time I heard that
Hillsdale had an honor code my older
brother came here when I heard that I
was like okay he's going to over in
school but that's what I expected he's a
weird guy the first time I was on campus
hearing dr. Arnn talk about the honor
code and the good the true the beautiful
and I cried I cried during that lecture
it was a little phonetic but it wasn't
like as dramatic as I am you know it's
just like a little the honor code just
like permeates out into like everything
that we do like you can see it in the
classroom
and the way that we respect our
professors in the way that we respect
other students in the way that we do our
homework in the way that like we want to
help one another
and we don't cheat and we don't we're
not cutthroat we're not trying to like
tear other students down there like
manipulate them but we're like want to
help one another and do it like in a way
that's honest and truthful yeah I think
when you view it as a list of rules you
miss out on all the good parts when it's
a way of life you choose things because
you love them and because you see them
as actually meaningful and beneficial to
you not because you have to it games
meeting and it becomes personal
Community College and being independent
you are away from your parents you have
a blank sheet to develop friends and
develop a reputation so taking ownership
of that was very important it took me a
while to develop that that ownership
another phrase you hear all the time at
Hillsdale is that colleges partnership
when you are aiming at such a high ideal
wanting to be people of excellence in
virtue you can't do that alone so having
a community of people that hold you to a
standard that encourage you that love
you that teach you that's powerful I
think the best way to take ownership of
who you're going to be in your four
years here is to find a community of
your peers that
hold you accountable and that when you
have to make those tough choices not
only you're holding yourself accountable
to something that the college expects
you to do but you're also holding
yourself accountable to a set of
standards that another community at this
campus has put forward for you to live
up to you
some of the relationships that you're
gonna build in the first three months at
college and you'd be like how did I not
know these people my entire life and
with that you have to recognize the
strength that is found in those
relationships and you have to be willing
to call people out with certain things
and understand that you want to be the
type of run to other people that you
would like them to meeting you
friendship really comes to a head when
there's conflict or you know that your
friend would be hurt if you spoke truth
I think in those moments it's selfish as
a friend to just tell them what's
comfortable to preserve your friendship
now and hurt them in the long run it
shows real true bravery to stand up and
help somebody in their time of need and
it kind of shows the exact opposite that
cowardice if you if you're kind of
shrinking away from something that looks
wrong or you know okay maybe I should
say something but I mean you know they
probably know what they're doing but
know if you see something wrong it's
step up and say something
stand up for yourself and stand up for
others that need it there's certainly a
lot of shenanigan ory that goes on but
we do hold each other to be to be
honorable
it is something integral to the very
fabric of what he'll say is we have a
lot of responsibilities here and
sometimes we subject ourselves to this
we're still children because we're still
in college idea or it's our only chance
to act like kids which means reckless
and making mistakes that you're going to
act like you don't regret for the rest
of your life and honor matters because
when you are honorable you are unified
you don't have a dissonance between what
you want to be and what you are it's the
little pieces of
day that you choose it's decisions
decisions decisions and they they shape
you and they form you and that is what
makes you honorable and all the things
that are outlined in our honor code
I think the person I want to be when I
leave here is is somebody that I looked
up to when I was fresher they exhibited
traits of a man to me when I was a young
man they showed what it meant to
approach work dutifully they showed what
it meant to stick by your word and
seeing those things exemplified in
somebody other than me I wanted to
emulate those people when I was younger
and I think that's just an amazing thing
that we get here I think it's all about
trust the faculty and staff trusting the
students and then the students trust in
the faculty and staff and when those two
things come together and like it's you
you can't see it until you like you just
like trust and you have faith and then
something really beautiful comes of that
the character is important because it is
life because it's how you interact with
the world because it's who you are
so making sure you have good character
is something that's incredibly important
because it is I mean yeah it is you
house a college student is honorable and
conduct honest and word indeed dutiful
and study and service and respectful of
the rights of others rising to education
no yes through education rising the self
government again oh man I memorize it
last night